selon les chiffres les plus récents on
consomme 53 litres de boissons gazeuses
sucrées par habitant par année au canada
et un peu plus de dix litres de boissons
gazeuses dit diète
malgré tout on consomme de moins en
moins de boissons gazeuses de 2013 à
2018 on avait un recul dans les ventes
en supermarché d'à peu près 9 points 5 %
ce qui est quand même énorme et dans les
ventes dans les débits de boissons les
restaurants on avait un recul de 14%
pour faire face au déclin les gros
joueurs de l'industrie s'ingénient à
trouver de nouvelles façons de nous
attirer ciblerait baies d'açaï on vise
l'abus régional effectivement envisagé
rations et on vise consommateurs qui
vont être séduits par cet argument que
bassil des fruits si le produit a vu un
bleu et quelque part dans sa production
ça doit être plus santé donc on joue sur
cette association mental là qu'on le
questionne potro qu'ils soient nouveaux
ou anciens les produits zéro calorie
diète et 0 sucre occupe beaucoup
d'espoir sur les tablettes c'est un
produit au départ pour offrir une
alternative par exemple pour gens qui
voulaient contrôler leur temps la
sommation au sucre comme les personnes
qui ont le diabète les édulcorants sur
des molécules qui imite le goût du sucre
est honteux pouvoir sucrant jusqu'à 600
fois supérieur à celui ci mais sans
fournir de calories
presque tous les édulcorants couramment
utilisés sont des produits de synthèse
dans le code l'aspartame et
l'association potassium ce sont des
molécules de synthèse c'est à dire qu'on
est capable aujourd'hui avec des acides
aminés de faire une synthèse qui permet
d obtenir mais la communauté
scientifique s'inquiète des effets sur
la santé de la consommation de ce type
de boisson
en continuant à consommer des boissons
gazeuses qui donne le goût sucré il ya
des chercheurs qui commencent à se
demander de quelle façon
l'organisme il répond le succès c'est
bon en soi c'est la surconsommation
problème il malheureusement de remplacer
avec du faux sucre ces sucres qui ne
sont pas calorique mais ça semble pas
réglé problème
le pire c'est que 60 d'exacerber même
auteur du livre la vérité sur le sucre
andre barrett est un chercheur de
réputation internationale depuis 20 ans
ces travaux sont axés sur les causes du
diabète
on a remplacé secret par des édulcorants
souvent malheureusement officielle donc
c'est des molécules chimiques et ce
qu'on s'aperçoit c'est que ces molécules
qui devait nous protéger au départ
contre les méfaits du sucre bessan est
en fait pas du tout avoir des effets
bénéfiques publiée dans le journal of
the american medical association jama
une nouvelle étude sur la consommation
de boissons gazeuses a été menée auprès
de plus de 450 mille personnes de 10
pays d'europe sur une période de 16 ans
est une des premières grandes études
épidémiologiques qui a permis de cerner
vraiment l'impact séparer des boissons
sucrées et des boissons édulcorées
malheureusement on sait maintenant qu'il
ya des effets directs le site
édulcorants de ces molécules chimiques
sur le microbiote intestinal
ces molécules actives des récepteurs
dans l'intestin et probablement nous
font croire qu'on ne
une prise de calories mais les galeries
à l'impôt derrière donc le cerveau qu
est-ce qui fait bénisse de consommer
plus parce qu'il faut compenser pour le
fait qu'on ait eu un goût sucré mais pas
de calories qui vient avec
dans l'étude on constate en effet une
prise de poids chez beaucoup de
personnes qui consomment des boissons
avec édulcorants donc du coca cola diète
audi coca cola normal les risques sont
les mains de nombreuses études dont
celle de jamal confirme que les gens qui
consomment 2 vert et plus par jour de
boissons gazeuses ont plus de risque de
mourir prématurément
et ce qui était observé par ce sont des
études observationnelles d'association
c'est que les grands consommateurs de
boissons sucrées mais même de boissons
sucrées édulcoré avec des faux sucre
développe peu plus de risques pour
l'obésité le diabète les maladies
cardiovasculaires
ce qui est très délicat auquel il faut
toujours faire attention la partie la
population qui est attiré par ces
boissons lors d'autres facteurs de
risque est-ce que la prise de boissons
sucrées édulcoré est un marqueur d'une
mauvaise hygiène de vie qui fait que les
jeunes enfants qui consomment ces
boissons ont beaucoup d'autres facteurs
de risque et menacé problème on sait pas
devrions nous alors nous tourner vers
les boissons utilisent plutôt un
édulcorant d'origine naturelle andré
marie travaille actuellement sur
l'impact des méthodes industrielles de
transformation du stévia il reste
prudent
c'est vrai que ça vient d'une plante
c'est déjà un avantage par rapport à un
produit chimique comme l'aspartame
mais encore fallait-il qu'on fasse des
recherches rigoureuses
il ya beaucoup de recherches que l'effet
sur le stévia souvent des recherches qui
ont été financées par l'industrie du
stévia savait pas dit que c'est pas
d'abord recherche on sait que j'ose dire
qu' il faut quand même avoir de la
recherche qui fait de façon indépendante
de l'industrie
aussitôt qu'il ya des études qui
viennent de démontrer un effet négatif
on va réviser et on va réévaluer
éventuellement on pourrait refuser
il faut que santé canada entre autres et
d'autres organismes font vraiment une
réévaluation du risque associé à ces
produits
pas seulement le risque pour la toxicité
le cancer mais le risque pour des
complications métaboliques à long terme
qui vont mener éventuellement à plus
d'obésité peut-être plus de diabète et
des maladies gastro intestinales la
recherche et les là pour l'ensemble
consommateurs si on est habitué à faire
un geste à chaque semaine à chaque jour
je pense pas que ces études là avec ce
niveau de connaissances là va venir
influencer le choix ça prendrait je
pense un peu plus de battage médiatique
pour sonner un signal d'alarmé pour dire
y fait attention là il ya vraiment
quelque chose là dont la lumière rouge
est allumée là il faut vraiment qu'on
soit conscient de ça et qu'on éduque la
population de faire attention ces
produits